[Music]
first of all we're girly girls we like
to be cute but we still get dirty
every time we come out our shoes our
outfits I always mention eye makeup is
done is it hard to write in heels no
because if you can walk in them you can
probably ride in we're not the typical
biker chick when the curves come on the
set is complete chaos
my name is true and I'm one of the
founders of caramel curves motorcycle
club here in New Orleans my name is Coco
and I'm one of the founders and the
president of caramel kurz motorcycle
club we are a motorcycle club like no
others we come our club ready every time
we hit the streets when we first started
off I just rolled by myself and then
Coco she just rolled by herself we kind
of got together and was like let's start
something together because the guys
always have their bike clubs but what's
more sexy than riding with a bunch of
girls nothing nothing at all
the name caramel kurz was made up by
luck we came up with caramel because of
the complexion of our skin and then we
came up with curse but soul reason but
when we take curves on a motorbike
better than a mane and we some curvy
girls we are mothers we are daughters we
are everything that every other average
woman is in a world I'm really really
passionate about female empowerment
women knowing that they can do whatever
they want to do
riding bikes used to be a guy thing
we're still being discriminated against
across the board being a caramel curve
we have demanded our respect I just
encourage any woman that wants to ride a
bike that thinks that she can't do it
girl you can do that [ __ ] you know go
ahead
the coolest thing about being a caramel
curve bike a chick is their response and
a love that we get from from kids up to
women when the little kids look up to us
it's that thing that makes her feel like
you know what if she can do it I can do
it you that's what makes you feel like
yeah you know what let's keep going we
going being a caramel Carter I truly
feel like is my legacy I'm gonna rock
cross country I'm gonna go live and I'm
gonna do it in heels
you
[Music]